[Music]
breakdown why you are here today
so Big Brother called myself and a bunch
of other pass house gets back to do BB
comics I get to hang out with people
from all over BB world who are you most
excited to see today
Nicole Franzel because y'all didn't know
already she's my girlfriend now and
obviously she lives in Michigan I live
in New Orleans so it was a kind of a
surprise trip that was kind of sprung up
on us and so I was obviously she was the
most I was most excited to see her how
did you and Nicole happen after the fact
so so post big brother me and Nicole we
stayed friends we talked a lot as
friends and you know through her life
and my life we were just an open book
and I think everything just came
together for the premiere of Big Brother
19 where we were in New York and we just
clicked and from then on it was I guess
like a love story and now she's my
girlfriend yeah cool very cool so it's
for a few months into this yeah yeah
yeah it's a it's exciting I'm I'm trying
to move over there I'm trying to move
over there to Michigan and stay over
there with her so kind of see how that
plays out but it's exciting she's
freaking awesome a lot of people don't
know her beyond Big Brother but she's
she's a sweetheart in real life and I
just I love her to death
Big Brother fans be surprised to learn
about her I guess accepting she is right
cuz a post Big Brother Victor you know
how fit Vic was a little bit wild right
you know you get the little taste of
what Fame is and you know you have all
these fans and stuff so you know I'm not
gonna lie my maybe went a little crazy
but I owned down and I and I calmed down
and Nicole accepted me regardless you
know because that was my past and now
I'm here and I'm the loyal guy that you
know that's with her and it's yeah she's
she's just awesome for accepting me for
who I am that's that I think that that
people don't
don't know how accepting she really is I
love that
[Music]
Oh